[Music]
more homeless encampments have been
popping up around the country in the
wake of the recession caused by covet
19.
from philadelphia to portland officials
are working to move people from
encampments into shelters but some
advocates for the homeless say the
emergency shelter model isn't working
instead they endorse what's called a
housing first approach
giving people forced into homelessness a
permanent place to live
and those advocates say the change has
reduced homelessness in places like new
orleans
new york and colorado where barry
peterson reports
some things are obvious at this busy
denver construction site
like how these 14 units are so small
they are called
tiny houses and the not so obvious that
these tiny houses
may make a big difference in solving
homelessness
housing solves homelessness and so the
only way that we're going to solve
homelessness is to
continue building housing how much space
are we talking about here
96 square feet there will also be a
front porch that attaches
here in front of the double doors cole
chandler is an ordained mennonite
minister who
organized and now runs the tiny house
project called
colorado village collaborative so
we provide people their own space their
own four walls their own door that they
can lock a place that they can store
their things keep their pets
and and rebuild their lives the first 11
unit tiny house project
was built three years ago a shared
kitchen
shower and bathroom are all in one
building
it's tough on the streets when you don't
have a place to take care of yourself
and rest and
do all that being here offered robert a
way off
the streets i have my own bed i have a
table there to
eat and study and my own fridge and
i would say spacious enough to for a
person to live and
have space to keep all their stories and
stuff in with five thousand homeless in
denver
these are meant to be a transition to
long-term housing
like this 31 unit apartment building in
boulder colorado
that was built to give the homeless a
permanent place to live
where we met ray vose who builds
electric bikes in his apartment
that can sell for about eighteen hundred
dollars
oh my word these are the electric
bikes this is the current project this
is amazing
well that one there is my daily driver
right now
what was the worst night or the worst
day
that you had when you were homeless
right i was sitting in a barn
spending my last two bucks and change on
up here
it was called and you know
just remember reading stories about
freezing to death
you know it's not that painful you know
you feel warm i was considering giving
up
yeah just going out and freezing to
death yeah
now those has a place of his own here
residents sign a lease and pay rent as a
portion of any income
such as social security or disability
greg harms ceo of boulder shelter for
the homeless
lays out the rules just like anybody
else who lives in an apartment
if you're going to have your friends
over and have loud parties that's not
acceptable
right if you're going to trash your
apartment that's not acceptable
if you don't pay your rent that's not
acceptable as long as you meet the
obligations of your lease
while you're staying here you know
you're welcome to stay once
there is housing then comes dealing with
problems like
alcohol and drug abuse illness
unemployment
so there's not a requirement that you
become sober there's not a requirement
that you get on your meds there's not a
requirement that you
you find employment because what we
found is when you put those requirements
in place
then people are are inevitably not able
to
to meet one of those requirements and
their housing is in jeopardy
and that's that's not the goal the goal
is to keep them housed
what happens with my next social
security check housing first has its
critics
chief among them robert marbert jr
president trump's
executive director of the u.s
interagency council on homelessness
he favors heavy policing like that seen
in cities that dismantle homeless
housing on the streets
but housing first actually cuts down
cost
of police time dealing with the homeless
and housing the homeless
in jail what other studies show about
the cost of housing versus the cost of
law enforcement
well to house somebody in a permanent
supportive housing program is fifteen to
twenty thousand dollars
the cost if they're on the streets is
probably about forty forty five thousand
dollars
half half less than half michael doherty
is the boulder county
d.a why is this better for the community
i think we're all better served having a
place where homeless individuals can
stay and i
be connected to resources and housing
that they need
and i think that's a better long-term
approach makes fiscal sense
and it's also more humane the hardest
sell is to neighbors
who fear violence what do you say then
greg to people who
look at the idea of putting something
like this in their neighborhood and
they're like no
no no we don't want you know
drug users and alcoholics and we don't
want police coming all day
and all night it hasn't been our reality
and if you look at the crime map of
boulder
the area that we're in right now is
probably one of the the safest and
least crime reported areas in the in the
city
every day in boulder just like across
america
there are still homeless who come for a
meal and a bed for a night
they came out of india but with housing
first there are more and more
like revo's i'm enjoying building these
e-bikes and you know i've sold
one bite to a neighbor um
and you know maybe that's maybe that's
something that can happen
um the point here is that there is now a
chance for
something to happen yeah you look
forward
yes yes
a life now with the chance to head
in the right direction for cbs this
morning
saturday barry peterson boulder
the smile the twinkle in his eye that
you saw at the end there
something humane it's cheaper than
living on the street and
you're off the street the value you give
somebody when you give them that place
of permanence
if nothing has worked in the past while
i try to try it yeah